so what's like to have been back
reunited with cast and crew uh
it's really indescribable yeah I mean
you would think after 11 years that it
it would be really different the first I
would say the first three episodes I
felt I was a little boy because I was
nervous but now we are full blast
fullback and it really it literally
feels like no time has passed where do
you think the nerves came from oh
definitely it was it was self-inflicted
like you know expectations wanting to to
you know make people laugh wanting
people who really loved the show to be
happy about you know what we were doing
and what we were bringing back so I
think that was where the nerves were I
mean and also I mean all four of us have
said this you know the biggest
difference is that you know we're not as
agile physically as we were I mean you
know I look back at the old episodes and
I was falling over couches and I mean
which is why I sprained my neck 7,000
times but we don't really do that so
much anymore and I think that's that's
really the only really big difference
what do you think that sense of pressure
comes from is it just a result of the
show being so adored and so successful
that you're like we want it to be yeah I
think that well first of all I think
part of it is because it was
unprecedented
I mean no show has has come back 11
years after it's wrapped and so nobody
knew what to expect and I think you know
being a control freak that that was
uncomfortable for me not knowing how it
was gonna happen and then I think yeah I
think we you know we decided that when
we were going to go off the air we we
had a cast meeting and we all decided
you know we that we wanted to give the
writers enough time to plan our exit so
that we wrapped it up beautifully you
know and because we we thought it was a
legacy these eight
so the decision to come back you know
for me was like we need to be coming
back for a reason you know and and
everyone has to have a plan and everyone
has to be on this on the same wavelength
because you don't mess around with that
you don't just say okay oh let's just
come back you know it's it's too
meaningful too so so many of us who were
part of the family and the beautiful
thing is that we when we came back we
were all on the same wavelength and I
actually feel like the shows are better
than they then even the first go-round
they're amazing um thank you for saying
that I mean it really feels it feels
fresh but it feels like a reunion with
your old friends and I think because all
of us are older and wiser I think that
there's you know a new depth that's you
you know the characters and the writing
that that wasn't there when we were
doing it the first go-round how you know
the show I've spoken to some of the
other cast mates about this show being
something that really pushed boundaries
in terms of sexual orientation and those
sorts of things how important is it to
you now eleven years later to still be
pushing those sorts of boundaries oh
it's it's incredibly important to me um
I'm gonna pause for a second because I'm
gonna sneeze it was a good one though so
tell me when you're ready okay
it's incredibly important to me you know
obviously when we when we started the
show our our main goal was to make
people laugh and you know that still is
but after the second season and we
started getting letters from people that
was when we realized that it really had
a a social and political impact that was
was very important to a lot of people
and and I know that when I saw Vice
President Biden say on Meet the Press
that it had done more to you know push
the
LGBT people LGBTQ community and they're
in the right direction that you know in
that moment I felt
besides the birth of my son that that
was the proudest moment of my life to
you know be a part of this thing that
had that kind of impact and you know
especially especially now in America
because the new administration is really
pushing back against progress and really
trying to roll back so many of its
social policies and policies that have
to do with the quality and and freedoms
I think it's more important than ever
before for us to do what we always did
which is to be funny but to be
provocative and to shine a light on
hypocrisy or you know thing places in
our culture where we can do better and
to make people laugh at the same time
and to hopefully start a dial
block also and
I
I was part of the thing that me
he was like we need a reason to come
back
for me that was part of the reason